[Music]
one of the biggest buildings in the
world there for the first time in nearly
half a century nasa has a rocket inside
that building capable of sending
astronauts back to the moon the space
launch system rocket is taller than a
football field is long and more powerful
than the iconic saturn v rocket from the
apollo program which last flew way back
in 1973.
nasa is now preparing its new moon
rocket for the first test launch in the
months ahead and our mark straussman got
an up-close look he shows us now nasa's
new timeline for lunar landing
both iconic and daunting nasa's vehicle
assembly building is one of the largest
in the world but obviously you need
something this big for for a vehicle
this big towering inside a new rocket
that makes you feel just as puny it's
called the space launch system or sls
this thing is massive it's about 322
feet tall so that's taller than the
statue of liberty we had to step way
back with nasa test director dan flores
to get a good look at the most powerful
rocket ever built if you look past the
scaffolding you can see the nose of the
two boosters yep
how powerful so the boosters provide
about seven million pounds of thrust
that liftoff that's a lot of power it's
a lot of power
nasa spent 11 months stacking this mega
rocket piece by piece
the core stage 212 feet long arrived by
barge its four engines will produce
another two million pounds of thrust you
got a rope up in there cranes gingerly
lifted and lowered billions of dollars
of space hardware into place
and then at the very top
the very top you have orion
orion is the crew capsule flores took us
up
311 feet for a closer look when you're
looking at this close you look at all
the hundreds of thousands of nuts and
bolts that have to be torqued
the hours spent by our technicians
getting this work done to get us to this
major milestone and every one of those
boats better be perfect
they better be right that's because
early next year this rocket and capsule
will roll to the launch pad for a
critical test flight artemis one
sls will launch orion on a course 40 000
miles beyond the moon and back no
astronauts will be on board this flight
but it's the first in a series of
increasingly complex lunar missions
we've got a moon bound rocket stacked
with a crew capsule for the first time
since
apollo 17 in 1972. oh this is a big deal
and it is beautiful and it is a monster
after more than 30 billion dollars in
development costs nasa administrator
bill nelson knows the pressure is on for
that test flight to go well i
am an optimist by nature true
space flight is risky and there are
penalties that you pay because
mistakes are made by human beings the
next mission artemis 2 will have a crew
it's due to fly around the moon by may
2024
nasa is now hoping artemis 3 a moon
landing using spacex's starship happened
sometime in 2025.
that crew will include the first female
moonwalker and astronaut kayla behrens
one of the candidates if they ask who
wants to go to the moon first you're
raising your hand oh yeah i think we all
raised our hands like who would not want
to go to the moon whatever the crew ends
up being we're going to be pumped for
each other but first the most complex
rocket in history has to work
america's lunar future depends on it
for cbs mornings mark strassman at the
kennedy space center
mark strassman with access that is truly
out of this world